Russian President Vladimir Putin has
granted American dissident Edward
Snowden Russian citizenship and
what do we think
we think on the one hand Edward Snowden
is a dirty rotten traitor who revealed
National Security secrets to the press
and undermined American interests and
hegemony abroad
or or we think that Edward Snowden
sacrificed his own comfort and security
in the United States to blow the whistle
on the overreach of the American
Security State which routinely spies on
American citizens without our knowledge
or consent
which is it
do you have an opinion about that
because I conducted a highly scientific
Twitter survey asking conservatives and
only conservatives their opinion of
Edward Snowden over 36 percent said that
they viewed Snowden as the good guy just
9.3 percent said they viewed Snowden as
the bad guy
and the plurality
37.1 percent said they didn't know
that's the craziest part
the largest group of conservatives said
they just didn't know what to think of
Snowden followed by the next largest
group which supports him why because
those conservatives rightly recognize
that the American national security
state has been weaponized by the radical
left they recognize as Christopher
Caldwell observed in a recent column
that the United States abroad is the
radical left
it is which explains I think the recent
Resurgence of isolationism in U.S
politics
Americans support our own country above
the other guys we're Patriots but we
understand that the U.S is the chief
exporter of wokism abroad and so we seek
to defend our interests as best we can
while constraining the exportation of
woke leftism which virtually every Power
in the world Western and otherwise has
recognized
all of which is to say no one really
cares about Edward Snowden and no one
really cares about the projection of
American power per se around the world
what we care about
is the power that we are projecting what
are we doing are we spreading truth
justice in the American way or are we
raising Pride Flags in Kandahar
what we most care about I think is the
power being projected by the ruling
class at home and what we ultimately
care most about is the power of being
exercised against us and against our
interests that's not a problem that will
be solved by facing down some foreign
foe that is a problem that can only be
solved by Shoring up the divisions
within our own borders which Joe Biden
and the ruling class seem hell-bent on
exacerbating every single day I'm
Michael knowlesis the Michael Knowles
show
foreign
[Music]
comment yesterday is from Road King Thor
who says are Cities Safe
Karine Jean-Pierre I'm not a biologist
that's true you can say our City's safe
I'm not an urban planner our City's safe
I'm not a criminologist or I guess you
could say our city safe I'm not a
biologist I don't know is the man who
was just stabbed dead or alive I don't
know I'm not a biologist that's what we
that's what we do on the left we just
play ignorance while America Burns don't
do that the country is in a lot of
trouble okay we might be heading down
the road to Perdition but at least you
can look good while all of that happens
if you want to look good you got to
check out mizen and Maine I absolutely
adore Missin and Maine these guys are
the inventors of the performance fabric
dress shirt company was born when
missing and man's founder saw a sweat
drenched DC staffer running into a
meeting wrinkled stained exhausted
disgusting this man's shirt needed a
refresh that is what drove Miss it in
Maine to make the world's first
performance fabric dress shirt 10 years
later they now make incredibly
comfortable flannels uh no tuck shirts
performance polos I especially love the
performance follows chinos so much more
they're just great the thing I love
about it is how it feels especially me
I'm of the Sicilian extraction we
perspire a little bit okay but more than
that I care about how it looks okay it
just the style is just smart and it's
kind of like the best of prep and sleek
and smart it means a little bit of
modern it's just really really great if
you want the best dress shirts money can
buy check out missing and Main right now
if you go to visit in maine.com use
promo code Knowles you will receive 35
off any regular price order of 125 bucks
or more that's 35 bucks off when you go
to
m-i-z-z-e-n-a-n-d-m-a-i-n.com use promo
code Knowles I don't know how I'm
supposed to feel about Edward Snowden
how am I supposed to feel
I I don't like that he revealed American
Secrets to the world because I like
America
I do like that he blew the whistle on
the widespread spying that our own
government is doing on us without our
knowledge or consent
I don't know what am I supposed to think
I don't I don't I think I'm with that
plurality of Americans of conservatives
even in my Twitter poll
I don't know
I want to project American strength
abroad I want America to be dominant and
growing and and Powerful but I don't
want to raise Pride flags all over the
world I don't want to export
transgenderism all over the world I
think that's really bad if that is what
American power is then I don't want to
export American power I don't want to
project American power but I want to be
a powerful country so what do we do
we're all just sort of stuck
we're all just sort of stuck this is why
the isolationism is creeping back up
because we just don't what do we do
are we are we for a strong America well
yes I'm for a strong America I don't
think transgenderism and all the crazy
woke stuff we're exporting makes us
stronger but if we're not involved in
the world stage then we're going to be
weaker but if we project transgenderism
I guess we're going to weaken those
other countries but we're just going to
basically weaken everybody what do we do
this that is what American power is
there is an insane notice that just came
out from the office for civil rights out
of the Department of Health and Human
Services
which raises a question first of all why
is there an office for civil rights at
the health department
why why does every Department seem to
have an office for civil rights I get
why the doj would have an office for
civil rights why the health department
but here's what they're saying by the
way what is the Civil Rights is it
making sure
you know black people have access to
public accommodations no
no they're saying HHS
is giving guidance on gender affirming
care
civil rights and patient privacy
the Department of Health and Human
Services stands with transgender and
gender non-conforming Youth and their
families and the significant majority of
Expert Medical associations in
unequivocally stating that gender
affirming care for minors when medically
appropriate and necessary Hint it is
never medically appropriate and
necessary improves their physical and
mental health so the office for civil
rights
is defending transiting the kids now
just transiting adults which is bad
enough transiting the kids
if that is what civil rights law means
if civil rights law means transiting
little kids and chopping off their
genitals I guess I'm against it
I'm for civil rights like the idea of
civil rights I like protecting actual
civil rights in practice
I'm sure against this
so what do we do
if the if the civil rights law can be so
misinterpreted as to mean pumping Little
Johnny full of estrogen
then we need to radically reform the
civil rights law then civil rights law
doesn't have really anything to do with
civil rights certainly doesn't have
anything to do with the right
not just the right meaning the
conservatives the right meaning what is
true and good
this is what we're projecting this is
what the American okay let's blow the
whistle baby I guess you don't need to
blow the whistle on this they're sending
out their own press releases
that is a very very woke deep State and
the Deep State the kind of permanent
bureaucracy seems to be running the
government a hell of a lot more than you
are and it's certainly running foreign
policy the Deep state is run foreign
policy since World War II
so
what are we left with
we're left with an insane
unaccountable government that
manipulates laws to whatever end they
have that is spying on you that wants to
take your kids away from you if you in
any way contradict the new Orthodoxy
that says that little Johnny's got to
lose his most precious body part
yeah I
that kind of makes me like Edward
Snowden more I know that these aren't
exactly
the same issue but they're all kind of
related right now so I have a great deal
of not just sympathy empathy with the
conservatives who say yeah maybe he's
not the worst guy
speaking of the woke deep State there's
more news on the The Mark Hauck story so
mark houg he's that pro-life author he
peacefully protests outside of abortion
clinics he prays he lets women know that
they have other options they don't have
to kill their kids and so the FBI of
course had to show up to his house with
dozens of Agents rifles pointed at Mark
and his wife in front of their seven
kids traumatizing them and Hall mark off
to prison because he says maybe we
shouldn't kill quite as many babies so
the story has somehow gotten even worse
because now attorneys for Mark Houck are
saying that way back in June months ago
when when this issue this this
altercation that took place outside an
abortion clinic came up even though it
was sort of laughed out of court
Mark Houck offered to go in and talk to
the FBI and the doj he said look if you
guys want to indict me over this which
you know I don't think you should but
I'm willing to voluntarily come in and
talk to you
doj did nothing about that no that
wouldn't be as glitzy that that wouldn't
be as Sensational that wouldn't be as
clear a demonstration of force against
conservatives and Christians and
pro-lifers
so the ignore Mark's offer to come in
peacefully and they they load up all
their guys with armor and a bunch of
rifles and point them at this guy's head
and point them at his wife
and point them all around the house in
front of the seven kids
that's the FBI that's the doj give me
more Edward snowden's I guess
I wouldn't have said that five or ten
years ago but I didn't realize how
corrupt the FBI and the doj were and as
I said the other day when the story
first broke
I blame the agents here I think enough
of this nice guy conservative well you
know it's the corrupt political
leadership at the doj but the agents are
the good guys yeah I'm sure they're good
at FBI agents in fact I know some good
FBI agents
but these these aren't the good guys
these aren't the political leaders at
the FBI or the appointed officials at
the doj these are the regular
run-of-the-mill agents acting like Jack
booted thugs private police for our
corrupt government our corrupt political
ruling class that goes in and points
guns at pro-life Advocates these people
should be ashamed of themselves they
should apologize
they should all resign
they're they're really really giving a
bad name
to not just their agency to not just the
Deep state to the whole country
okay and it makes people
feel embarrassed and ashamed of the
country it makes people not want to
project American power abroad because we
think if this is the power pointing guns
at pro-life authors because they dare to
say that we shouldn't kill babies then I
don't want to project that power
you know what I want I want to do things
for myself like fix my car when I want
to fix my car where do I go rockauto.com
right now head on over to rockauto.com
write Knowles in there how did you hear
about us box with the ever increasing
numbers a vehicle makes and models it is
impossible for a traditional chain
storefront to stock all the parts that
you need why wait while the man at the
counter orders parts for your car from
the brand that his Warehouse happens to
carry you have a computer in your pocket
just go to rockauto.com rockauto.com has
been in the auto parts business for 20
years family owned their goal is to make
Auto Parts available and affordable to
keep you safe on the road they not only
have the auto parts you need they will
give you a selection of trusted name
brands to choose from you can pick
whatever you need the breaks that match
how you use your vehicle for towing
racing or just commuting to work you can
get suspension exhaust air conditioning
and other kits that provide all the
parts that you need for a successful
repair super easy no gimmicks same
prices for pros and do-it-yourselfers
the catalog is so easy to navigate even
I can do it what do you do you head on
over to rockauto.com right now get
brakes shocks carpet wipers headlights
mirrors Mufflers lug nuts any other part
that you need rockauto.com be sure to
write nulls in their head did you hear
about this box so they know that we sent
you
speaking of the deep State and
Corruption
you know I don't know if you heard about
this crazy conspiracy theory there's a
crazy lunatic conspiracy theory goes
back to covid that if a mother if a
nursing mother
gets the covid vaccine that that could
affect her baby
that it could end up in the baby if
she's pregnant or if the baby's already
been born and the baby's nursing the
covet vaccine could end up in the breast
milk and that's a crazy insane radical
crazy conspiracy theory up whoops it's
true
new study
published on Monday
reveals what they say it's just Trace
Amounts
not a lot
little tiny amounts of covid vaccine
mrnas
found in the breast milk of lactating
women this is not some Fringe crazy blog
this is from the Journal of the American
Medical Association
and international peer review journal
that's been publishing for for many
decades and the journal says quote
caution is warranted regarding
breastfeeding infants younger than six
months in the first two days after
maternal covid-19 vaccination
why is caution warranted
one of course we were told that the
vaccines don't affect babies in any way
so and then that turned out to be a lie
but why is caution warranted I was told
the vaccine is 100 safe it's wonderful
everyone should get it everyone should
get multiple shots kids especially oh
yeah even though kids face pretty much
zero risk from coronavirus no they got
to get those shots let's so why would
caution
be warranted because obviously the
vaccine has side effects some of which
are dangerous some of which are deadly
and they're slowly admitting this
and and those of us who called it from
the very beginning who said yeah I
probably wouldn't get this vaccine yeah
it doesn't seem like a good idea I don't
know coven doesn't seem all that bad
relative to other plagues in the history
of the world and this vaccine is
untested technology seems like there's a
lot of risk here and so I'm just not
going to do it we were called crazy
conspiracy theorists we were kicked off
of social media in some cases episodes
of this show were censored by the big
Tech platforms now it turns out it's all
true this is the Clinton strategy this
is what the clintons used to do when
they get caught up in a scandal
they'd get accused of some Scandal that
they were obviously guilty as Sin of and
they say no that didn't happen
and they deny deny deny deny
deny deny deny deny deny and then when
it was finally completely undeniable
they would say oh that's old news
oh are you still talking about that
that's old news no it's not old news
you you've been lying to me this whole
time you've been gaslighting me this
whole time now you're telling me it's
old news oh yeah of course the vaccines
are dangerous yeah no of course yeah of
course you know caution is is warranted
yeah yeah what's the big deal well the
big deal is you I've been saying that
for years and you've been calling me a
crazy person I feel like a crazy person
what do you be but you're the crazy
people I'm the one saying the cough's
not all that bad and the vaccine has
some side effects and wearing a little
hanky in front of your face for two
years is not orderly and it's not going
to save the public okay and uh I don't
know I'm the one who's been saying that
maybe we shouldn't chop off the genitals
of little kids and I'm the one that's
been saying that it's actually probably
not a great idea to kill all the little
babies and you've been calling me the
crazy one
and you've been projecting all this
Insanity abroad
but you got you guys are The Crazy Ones
you're gonna I'm not crazy
I'm not crazy it is it is the American
ruling class that is crazy and it's why
we don't want to encourage them
that's why we all are just kind of
standing still right now
speaking of
mothers
speaking of
marriage love marriage and the baby
carriage a woman reportedly feels very
violated this is a daily wire story she
feels violated because a court is
ordering her to hand over racy photos to
her ex-husband in a divorce
the judge has ordered me to give nude
photos of my body to a third party that
I don't know without my consent
and the third party here it's not quite
as bad as the headline makes it sound
it's that the the woman took some
Boudoir shots I guess for her hubby and
now they're getting divorced and in the
settlement the husband gets to keep some
of the photos but the the judge is
saying okay lady you don't need to hand
over the nude photos but you have to
hand them back to the photographer who
took the photos and he's going to sort
of airbrush that out and edit them a
little bit so that your husband doesn't
have porn of you but he gets to keep the
memories and even the inscriptions on
the photos and the woman has a problem
even that he gets the inscriptions
forget about the photo she goes even
those inscriptions were kind of racy and
sensual and I I don't want him to have
those
that's wrong that's that's the sort of
thing a wife gives her husband
right right lady you're so close it's
amazing how I didn't I didn't pack it
with me you know I'm traveling right now
I didn't pack the world's tiniest violin
with me because I just fear that
sometimes when you're going through
airport security sometimes they can
break your world's tiniest violin but
had I brought it with me I would
certainly be playing it for her right
now
this woman is in no way a victim
if you don't want pornographic photos of
yourself out there don't take them
definitely don't send them to people
okay she took them she gave them to her
husband
now they're out there play stupid games
Win stupid prizes okay and now what's
the price she says well it's not even
the pornographic photos it's that he has
them
those are photos that a wife gives to
her husband right lady he's your husband
if you if you if you don't want someone
who's not your husband to have those
photos
don't get divorced
well it's not that simple Michael we
have irreconcilable differences we don't
like each other okay okay fine
so you don't take your marriage vows
seriously
you couldn't work it out for whatever
reason okay I don't even need to know
the details fine
you play stupid games you win stupid
prizes you know there are consequences
to actions in the world right does this
lady know that I don't know that she
does
this is this is increasingly defining
our culture people do ever more insane
things
with the expectation that there will
never be any consequences of those
things that they will have to live with
and it can be really heartbreaking too I
mean this is kind of a stupid story but
it can be really heartbreaking I see
these these stories of transgender
regret all the time
uh Seth Dillon from the battle on me was
just posting screenshots of these
letters from people who said I
transitioned when I was 14 and I've
completely destroyed my body and it's
irreversible and I I'm unlovable I I I I
can't look at myself in the mirror all
these really heartbreaking
heartbreaking stories and obviously I
don't blame the kids for doing that
they're 14 year olds 14 year olds are
stupid and they make insane Reckless
decisions that's kind of the definition
of a 14 year old
I certainly blame the parents
I certainly blame
the cultural figures that are promoting
this
I certainly blame the office for civil
rights at the Department of Health and
Human Services I certainly blame Joe
Biden
I I blame those American officials
I blame them personally they everyone is
just trying to get out of consequences
say what you will about Edward Snowden
again I told you I don't really know
what to think about Snowden part of me
thinks he's a traitor part of me thinks
he blew the whistle on an important
story
say what you all about Snowden he
accepted the consequences of what he did
nobody in the Deep state to my knowledge
has ever had to accept the consequences
of their nefarious actions Snowden said
okay I'm going to give up I'm going to
give up my comfortable life my
my position as an American I'm gonna go
have to live in Russia
okay that's that's the consequences of
of blowing the whistle all right
at least give the guy credit for that
if you if you don't want this is my PSA
today you can you can have a the more
you know logo underneath if you don't
want nude photos of you going to
your ex-husband don't do porn and don't
get divorced there you go problem solved
speaking of Separation there's a really
really uh scary though totally expected
study that just came out that loneliness
loneliness increases aging
more than cigarettes do this is a story
out of Hong Kong but it's a sort of
international team of scientists people
from Hong Kong people from Stanford
University in the United States they say
that being unhappy
or experiencing loneliness
accelerates the aging process more than
smoking
and damages the body's biological clock
increases the risk for Alzheimer's
diabetes heart disease and other
illnesses this in the journal aging I
think we all know this
and yet
we don't treat it as a public health
problem this is one of the most
important public health problems that
we're facing today
and no one wants to deal with it in fact
it's really not just the libs they're
the ones pushing this but both sides of
the aisle are exacerbating that problem
the problem of loneliness we tend to
think of Public Health and most
political questions in our day and age
as just material questions well we can't
take into account spiritual concerns or
metaphysical concerns so we're just
going to deal with flesh and matter and
the reason people are unhappy and now
dying and not living as long as they
used to in the United States not having
kids non-forming families the reason is
just because they don't have enough
money that we just need to forgive their
student loans oh the reason is that they
don't have enough stuff no that's not
why there's something deeper that has
frayed here
and the the real issue is a complete
breakdown of the sense of American
community
the sense the sense not only that we
have a place in America that our
political opponents are our fellow
citizens I think that is almost entirely
afraid not only that the different
states have a relationship to one
another but even within our own families
that we have any real connection or
obligation or duty to our family members
the the left spins that off because they
hate the family and they hate
traditional institutions but the right
does it too because the right talks
about all this Babble Of only in only
looking at politics from the perspective
of individual rights and entitlement and
greed is good and go out there and make
money money and ignore your family and
ignore your your sort of obligations
well the consequence of both of those
policies is
you get what you pay for that that
political movements just like individual
actions have consequences and you play
stupid games you're gonna win stupid
prizes
we got we have to prioritize
dealing with the loneliness epidemic
which means we need to prioritize
rebuilding a sense of American Community
which means we need to prioritize having
a shared set of values and speaking a
common language which means we need to
prioritize discussions about the common
good not just our own individual rights
to do whatever the hell we want but
actually what we ought to do and we've
got to prioritize resolving those
debates and we've got to we've got to be
able to wield cultural institutions and
political institutions by the way to
shape and enforce that view of the
common good and I don't know that anyone
really wants to do it the radical Libs
obviously have done it and perverted our
whole system
but I don't I don't know that we have
the appetite to do that but it's the
only way to save the country
speaking of priorities
Karine Jean-Pierre
amid the economic turmoil amid the
immigration crisis historic immigration
crisis amid the first major war in
Europe since World War II amid all these
problems energy crisis
Kareen Jean-Pierre has her priorities in
order on the sort of conversations that
we need to have
the president hosting the Atlanta Braves
today wondering if you or the president
has any thoughts about some of the
controversial about the team name the
Braves name the so-called tomahawken
shop any thoughts on so we we believe
that it's important
um to have this conversation uh you know
and uh and Native American and
Indigenous voices they should be at the
center of this conversation
I I would like to issue a fact check
it is not in fact important that we have
that conversation
we do not in fact have to have the
conversation about changing the names
of the Atlanta sports team
we don't we don't need to do that it's
okay we have bigger fish to fry
it's okay Atlanta can keep the Braves
it's fine it's totally fine but for the
libs this is an important conversation
for the libs all these little issues are
always important conversations
because it's it's death to America by a
Thousand Cuts
we're going to we're gonna we're gonna
pervert the Civil Rights offices we're
going to change civil rights law to now
protect sexual orientation and gender
identity we're going to change the
curricula at the schools we're going to
open up the Border a little bit we're go
and a lot actually we're going to lock
people down a little bit where we can
we're going to force a few different
mandates on maybe the vaccines or on
maybe lactaids we're going to do this
and that and this and that we're going
to change the name of your sports teams
we're going to do everything all at once
and you're going to be so confused it's
going to be like whack-a-mole
you say wait what how are we doing wait
hold on what no you're changing my
sports team you're trying to trans my
kid you're calling you're telling me
that that I'm I'm evil because I'm white
you're telling me boom boom and where
whenever you hit the mold and another
one pops up
and it leads to
a kind of political impotence this is
the impotence of the plurality of
conservatives in my Twitter poll who
don't know what to think about Edward
Snowden we just think
I'm torn between these two polls I don't
what things are changing so fast I don't
know what to think there are more
important issues though and actually
speaking of Russia
the new British prime minister Liz Truss
has has just become probably the first
person even
near Europe
to start doing something proactive about
dealing with the energy crisis that is
causing all this crazy inflation and
that is a result of the Russian invasion
of Ukraine Liz truss has just lifted the
fracking ban in the UK
she's pushing for higher fossil fuel
production she has the goal now of
becoming a net exporter of energy by 20
40 and she's also cutting taxes so kind
of standard conservative policy but but
she is now
governing along the lines of drill baby
drill
and the libs are losing their minds over
this
increasing fossil fuel production is the
only alternative especially when we're
talking about the Europeans to
supporting Russia in the Ukraine war
another a classic example of the libs
thinking that they're never going to
have to deal with any consequences yeah
we're gonna we're going to expand NATO
recklessly into Ukraine we're going to
provoke Russia at every single chance we
can get we're then going to take the
sanctions off Russia's oil pipeline
which the president of Ukraine Vladimir
zielinski said is going to cause a
Russian invasion of Ukraine we're even
going to literally invite Putin to
invade parts of Ukraine when Joe Biden
says if if Putin just invades the
eastern part of Ukraine well if it's
just a minor incursion no big deal we're
going to do all that kind of stuff we're
going to destroy the Western Energy
sector especially in Europe because of
concerns over global warming or whatever
and then
we're not going to face any consequences
from that except that winter is coming
and the Europeans are entirely dependent
on Russian oil and now the Russians hold
all the cards and now Europeans are
going to freeze to death over the winter
unless something is done well okay we
got to do something okay well the thing
that you can do is drill and frag no we
don't want to do that okay then what are
you going to do you you have no clear
political Vision you want to just do all
of these incoherent things all at once
and what is the consequence of that it's
just total impotence
it's just waiting to freeze to death
that's that's what the Europeans are
doing
that's what Britain is not doing anymore
but that's what the Europeans are doing
and it's what we're all kind of doing in
a metaphorical sense here in the west
we're all just sort of waiting to freeze
to that we don't really want to disturb
the system too much we realize that the
system is inconsistent it's not really
working we don't
we want we want things that are
incoherent and contradictory and so we
just
we just stand still
speaking of oil Rich States Texas
you know is very attractive to many
Californians a lot of people fleeing
that state the U-Hauls are all moving in
One Direction We fled we didn't go to
Texas but we went kind of close we went
to Tennessee
well there's a major Californian
uh who is leaving for Texas now that
would be Governor Gavin Newsom
uh sorry Texans Democrat Governor Gavin
Newsom spoke at an event in Texas over
the weekend and this would not be
particularly noteworthy
politicians speak all over the country
all the time Gavin Newsom obviously
wants to run for president no surprise
that he's holding events in different
states except that
travel to Texas is explicitly banned
government traveled to Texas is banned
by California and it's banned by
California because Texas doesn't want to
trans the kids
there in 27 there was a measure that
went into effect in California
that took action because of North
Carolina's measures to keep the men in
the men's bathroom and the women in the
women's bathroom and it says that it
voids or repeals or has the effect of
voiding or repealing existing state or
local protect oh I'm sorry any state
that Voyager appeals or has the effect
of voiding or repealing existing state
or local protections against
discrimination on the basis of sexual
orientation gender identity or gender
expression uh those States you cannot
travel to as a government official
in California
so Gavin Newsom does it now Gavin
newsom's already done this kind of stuff
before he did it back uh over the summer
he went on a vacation to Montana Montana
is also one of these states and Newsome
said oh it's not a big deal it's not a
big deal no it's I it was just a
personal trip even though he brought his
security team with him no no it was a
personal trip so it doesn't count now
Gavin Newsom obviously knew that this
was a problem with the California law
because he didn't include the trip to
Montana on his schedule so he knew it
was a big issue he did it anyway
this is certainly violating that law
going to Texas doesn't matter he did it
anyway
why did he do it because the rules don't
apply to him and none of us are
surprised we know how there is there are
two systems of Justice in this country
and conservatives have the harsher one
right we're the ones who the libs can go
around and burn the country down for
eight months that's fine they get a slap
on the wrist if that conservatives if we
peacefully protest outside of an
abortion clinic we're going to have two
dozen gestapo agents kick in our door
and point rifles at us in front of our
seven kids that's just that's just the
way it works now Donald Trump
perfectly legally bring some documents
after he was president to Mar-A-Lago
what happens the Gestapo knocked down
the door and they raid the president's
home
but
right left-wing officials face no
consequences whatsoever frequently for
doing the very same thing we know that
we know that that happens and so
bringing you right back to thinking
about Edward Snowden you think well I I
love my country
but I can't say that I really like these
people who are running the country
because not only are they doing it in an
incompetent way in an unjust way in an
immoral way but they're actually coming
after me okay
they're coming after me for believing
perfectly ordinary things like don't
kill babies and don't trans the kids
it's just lawlessness and you're seeing
that lawlessness especially from Gavin
Newsom
Gavin Newsom is now
issuing government ID cards
to illegal aliens says we're a state of
Refuge a majority minority state where
27 percent of us are immigrants that's
why I'm proud to announce the signing of
today's bills to further support our
immigrant Community which makes our
state stronger every single day and
here's what the new law says the bill
would specify that immigration
enforcement as defined does not
constitute an Urgent health and safety
need for those purposes and would
prohibit a government agency or
Department law enforcement agency
commercial entity or other person from
obtaining accessing using or otherwise
disclosing the non-criminal history
information maintained by the department
for the purpose of immigration
enforcement they're saying not only are
we going to give these immigrants these
illegal aliens ID cards and treat them
increasingly like Citizens We're
actually going to prohibit the law
enforcement agencies from enforcing the
law
and why are they doing this
they're doing this obviously because it
helps them politically but this is de
facto amnesty if you're if you're
telling the law enforcement agencies
they can't enforce the law on illegal
immigration and then you're giving the
illegal aliens government issued ID
cards that is de facto amnesty we know
that Biden and the Democrats want
amnesty at the federal level but they
don't they actually don't even need it
as you have this kind of breakdown of
the national sense of unity
you're just going to see these things
happen at the state level
and just as as far right as Texas or
Tennessee is going that's how far left
you're going to see California go so
you've you've stopped giving your money
to woke razor companies that hate you
and you've bought Jeremy's razors
instead that's good glad to hear that
every dollar that we take away from the
left is one dollar saved from misuse but
that is a fringe benefit compared to the
Jeremy's razors contest for the car that
we've just launched here's how it works
for every person you refer whether they
buy a Jeremy's razor kit or a daily wire
annual membership you both get points in
the race to win the god Kings McLaren if
you refer enough people you just might
win it seriously a 3.8 liter V8 powered
sports car with hundreds more horsepower
even than my Honda Civic which is pretty
crazy I've got a pretty beefy car you
know now
I know that Matt thinks that he has the
most dedicated audience out there the
SBG but if one of you were to win I
would be able to prove him wrong so a
win for you is a win for me sign up and
start competing at jeremy'sraisers.com
play to race for the car ends on
November 1st so get in the competition
today most of the top players have not
hit 20 referrals yet so there is still
plenty of time for you to jump into the
race and win see terms and conditions
for complete details at Jeremy's
racers.com
referral terms the program is open only
to legal U.S residents residing in the
US and DC excluding residents Colorado
Connecticut Maryland Puerto Rico and U.S
territories and possessions 18 and older
remember friends don't let friends shave
with woke razors
speaking of Mexico
speaking of projecting American power
abroad this is a story that I wanted to
get to last week did not have the
opportunity to do so Matt Gates
Republican member of Congress has
some powerful plans for how to deal with
the illegal immigration problem and that
would be to bomb it out of existence
there has been discussion today of
Fentanyl and I it irks me every time I
hear someone talk about fentanyl
overdoses because no one overdoses on
fentanyl because I don't think anybody
really sets out to like score some
fentanyl for a good time since people
don't set out to use fentanyl since it's
something we don't want in our country
we should be totally capable of stopping
it and the only reason we aren't is
because we purposefully allow our border
to degrade not by accident not because
of some some lack of capability or some
unsolvable problem set but because there
are some groups on the right and left
who think that they will do better
economically if we just let millions of
people into the country and depress the
wages of Americans and the cost they're
willing to pay for that
are the funerals and the deaths and the
broken lives as a result of fentanyl
poisoning because it is not an overdose
it is a poisoning that happens
so so that's the argument that he's
making and the kind of climax to this
argument is let's let's go in and just
stop these cartels let's bomb these guys
I've made the same suggestion in the
past
why don't we do it
well yes I understand it would be
complicated you would destabilize the
Mexican Government such as it is and
because we don't have a wall yet that
would probably lead to an increased
surge of illegal aliens across the
border and so you'd have to do it in a
smart way okay sure I agree with all of
that sure I get it
but why is the suggestion laughed out of
the room why aren't people taking that
seriously why isn't the United States
the Deep State and the American Military
putting pretty much all of their focus
on that issue why are we invading Libya
why are we prancing around the Middle
East in frequently incoherent military
actions where we have an objective then
we sort of reverse the objective then we
just stay there for a while then we pull
out sort of arbitrarily why are we doing
that when we have an actual existential
problem on our Southern border where
giant criminal cartels are actually
poisoning our people so much so that the
life expectancy is decreasing and
flooding our country with foreign
Nationals a obviously a national
security risk a a mockery of our
constitutional government why aren't we
focused on that
why that should be the entire Focus
of our national security state in the
U.S military what do we have a military
for if we can't stop millions and
millions of people crossing our border
illegally every year by paying off some
of the worst most dangerous criminals on
earth right on our Southern border not
over in Libya not over in Syria right
there right on the other side of the Rio
Grande then what's it for what are we
doing what are we doing
oh well no the Deep state has other
plans they've got other priorities
they've got to spy on you they've got to
go kick down the door of pro-life
authors and point guns at his family
they've got to they've got really
important things they've got to go
harass the former president and chief
political rival to Joe Biden and invade
his home they've got really important
stuff
oh stopping the fentanyl from crossing
the border yeah they'll get to it when
they get to it stopping the two million
people that have come in the last year
illegally over the Border oh yeah well
we're just stretched real thin we don't
have the resources we got to go kick
down the doors of a few more pro-life
Advocates yeah sorry we got to go trans
some more kids this is a civil rights
issue this is a priority number one for
the Biden White House so yeah we'll get
we'll get to the the Fentanyl and the
criminal cartels and the flooding of our
country with foreign National we'll get
to that when we get to we just got to
trans a few more kids first
if that's our deep state I'm glad
somebody blew the whistle okay
and I think that's what a lot of people
feel
as well
speaking of things in which All is fair
such as not only War but love as well as
that for a segue
I also wanted to get to this last week
I'm glad we have the opportunity the
latest in the Adam Levine Saga yes I
have been following the story very
closely I'm not sure that I've ever
listened to more than one Adam Levine
song I you know here's the guy from
Maroon 5 and there was that one song
that was on the radio all the time but I
don't I don't follow this guy very
closely and the long and short of it is
he cheated on his wife apparently and
the women that he allegedly cheated with
are releasing all these DMS and they're
really really lame I bring up the story
not not to scold Adam Levine even for
doing a bad thing though he did do a
very bad thing uh not to even shame the
women for sleeping with a married man
which is very bad they shouldn't have
done that I bring up the story
to just point out how lame this whole
thing is
the Texas oh you're so effing beautiful
you're so effing hot oh my God he sounds
like like a weird Randy 12 year old boy
and it's so this is an adult with many
many millions of dollars with a family
with kids with another kid on the way he
said oh wow you're so effing hot and if
you if you've ever been tempted to cheat
on your wife or if you're being tempted
right now to cheat on your wife and
you're not persuaded to avoid doing that
because of God because of morality
because of your vows that you took to
your wife at least consider this
don't cheat on your wife because of how
freaking lame you're going to look oh my
gosh and the thing that is boggling
everybody's mind about this too is that
this guy who okay yeah Rockstar cheats
on his wife wow never heard that story
before it's I think gets the texting of
it all that is what's so weird about it
that this guy is sitting in his room at
night like I'm going to send naughty
little texts to these random women on
Instagram I think bro that is so sad and
lame but why is he doing it
and if the story is true that he did
cheat on his wife
how did that come about
he's doing it because of something that
we all fall into which is we believe
that the online world isn't real it's
not real Twitter's not real
porn isn't real
the flirty text messages the sort of
lame text messages with these Instagram
models that's not real that's just the
virtual life it's kind of whatever you
just doing it on your phone in the in
the dark with the blinds closed it's
okay then you're going to go back out
into your real life but it is real
and it it bleeds over into your real
physical life obviously
there there's a huge misconception I I
think in our culture because we have a
view of the mind and and virtue and and
the soul that suggests that we just need
to blow off steam sometimes you say okay
we're I'm just gonna go uh you know well
porn would be a great example actually
I'm just gonna blow off a little steam
I'm going to look at porn but that's
going to tame down my passions and so
I'm not gonna go cheat on my wife but
it's sort of the opposite is true
it actually just excites Your Lust it
just it just virtue and vice are just
habits and so the more you do of those
things the the more you're going to do
of them and and the more radically
you're going to express those things
and this is especially true in the
online to real world divide
if you start take gambling for instance
if you start gambling online and you
just play some of these little games and
you say oh it's just fun there's no real
money involved there's no there's no
real Stakes
very often that turns into a full-blown
gambling addiction and people lose real
money even though it seems like it's
just in this virtual world countless
stories of people who download these
stupid little games where it's a little
little colored blocks falling and and
then they end up losing lots and lots of
money tens of thousands of dollars
sometimes
because the online world the online life
really does matter
take it as a cautionary Tale
do not
do not I always heard this line don't
ever send an email that you wouldn't
want to read on the front page of the
New York Times
you can take it further do not send any
DMS to Instagram models that you would
not say in real life
to her face and that you would not want
to read on the cover of the daily wire
because that will that will be really
really sad for you speaking of frivolous
women huge huge shocking news from the
conservative on The View you know the
conservative on The View The View
that that group of cackling hens The
View has always a conservative and the
conservative usually is not a
conservative usually the conservative is
a Democrat who pretends to be a
conservative but now the Democrat who
pretends to be a conservative on the
view is saying that she might vote for a
Democrat
is it time for a third party I think it
might be because I think that the way
the parties are structured now in the
primary system we don't elect the most
qualified people we elect the people who
cater the most to the base which is the
minority of both parties rather than
people who are most likely to want to
get things done to work across the aisle
I'll say this I agree about halfway with
Liz Cheney I will full stop never
support an election denier I still want
to work from within with the Republican
party I believe politics is cyclical and
the Donald Trump moment which has
consumed all of us for so long will
eventually come to an end and I hope to
influence the party from within the
Donald Trump party is not a conservative
party it's a populist nationalist
right-wing party that I have about as
much in common with as I do Bernie
Sanders but I want to get back to
something where we are pro-free trade
pro-globalization for legal immigration
into the country securing the Border but
with legal immigration and that's just
not where we are now as far as
supporting Democrats um I'd be open to
on a case-by-case basis I'd have to look
at their policy yeah and that's kind of
where I am
that's where I am look I'm a
conservative I just look Donald Trump
he's not conservative because he wants
to conserve things you know and he he
believes in concern he's a he's a
right-wing person but I'm not I'm a
conservative and what do I support I
support things like free trade I support
things like Mass migration I support
things she goes down the list
she's she's presenting herself
not as a conservative she's presenting
herself as a Bill Clinton Democrat she
said you know like a conservative like
like Bill Clinton and he's like no lady
that Donald Trump is much much more
conservative than you are of course I
mean Hillary might be more conservative
than that lady is it's it's all just so
fake and listening to that I I sort of
sympathize with her because maybe in the
90s or sometime in the 2000s that might
have been what this the squishy
conservatives dominated the party and
that might have been what they thought
conservatism was just cut taxes flood
the country with foreigners and did I
mention cutting taxes yeah cut taxes and
have refrigerating globalism that's what
people thought it was
and now in large part thanks to Donald
Trump conservatives are waking up and
saying no actually conservatism is
deeper than just policies of Bill
Clinton okay with more like gay stuff
the Bible says that Bill Clinton with
more rainbow flags that that actually
conservatism runs a little bit deeper
than that we're kind of going back to a
tradition that is that is much deeper
and much more serious and and so in that
moment
the the squishes in the middle the
Alissa fera people really all of us
we're looking we're saying what does it
even mean what does it mean to be a
conservative what does it mean to be an
American Patriot that's why it's why
we're all stuck on this question what
the hell am I supposed to think about
Edward Snowden you know the rest of the
show is continuing right now you do not
want to miss it if you are a member
we are going to be getting to fake
headlines today I know it's it's woke
Wednesday we're supposed to get to a
woke commercial or or woke viral video
but I'm on the roads we're gonna swap it
this week okay we're gonna do the fake
headlines you've you've got to see if
you can guess which headline is fake uh
obviously we'll be chatting with you in
the daily wire remember Chad if you're
not already a member all right head on
over click the link in the description
and join us
[Music]
[Music]
thank you